[Música]
son el resultado de un trabajo
Monumental del hombre en simbiosis con
una naturaleza creativa para darle
nacimiento a los jardines más bellos de
Francia en alta córcega el parque de
salexia es un concentrado del
Mediterráneo un paraíso florido junto al
mar propiedad de la familia de bueno
demuestchee desde 1951 este ingeniero
horticultor lo creó desde cero
estoy haciendo una depresión de riego
apisoné la tierra alrededor del Terrón
Incluso hoy a sus 85 años trabaja allí
todos los días
es una zona un rincón mágico sí que ha
quedado virgen un poco gracias a
nosotros ya que ha habido urbanizaciones
muy importantes en este terreno se
proyectaron 180 Villas y había un centro
comercial en la playa con un enorme
estacionamiento
al clasificarlo como zona agrícola en la
década de 1960 la familia salvó el
terreno de los promotores que amenazaban
los olivos centenarios pero en 1974 el
fuego lo destruyó todo un terrible
incendio arrasó con la alta córcega
total
[Música]
quedan huellas como estos tocones
calcinados de Olivos lo arrasó
Prácticamente todo ya que de 1200 Olivos
quedaron 20 ver árboles desaparecer así
sabemos que es irremediable no lo
volveremos a ver e incluso muchas
generaciones no los volverán a ver
durante 25 años Bruno limpia injerta
planta de nuevo y del caos brota la
belleza siete hectáreas de plantas
árboles mediterráneos y flores
deslumbrantes uniden sobre él que ve la
Isabela la hija de Bruno
es un lugar al que ya veníamos en
familia cuando era pequeña
tuvimos muchas celebraciones familiares
aquí en salesia
y luego desde el 96 estoy trabajando en
el parque montándolo y entonces sí estoy
muy apegada
mucho más al norte El Jardines de estilo
italiano pero el castillo es bretón
cerca al Mustang Michelle los jardines
de la están clasificados como monumentos
históricos
la orgullosa propietaria de esta finca
cada mañana saborea la vista de este
paisaje toscano desde la ventana de su
Castillo
nunca me canso y a veces me digo pero es
raro y no
es como la gente que tiene la orilla del
mar pero no es el mar es el campo
a lo largo de las estaciones y
dependiendo de la luz del día
dependiendo por supuesto del clima
la iluminación Nunca es igual
una verdadera obra de arte cuyo artista
maneja Las tijeras Como nadie rompe el
jardinero jefe de este parque que
requiere cuidados diarios
Al final todo es parte de una pintura en
medio del césped
sería una pena tener árboles y arbustos
que tienen formas un poco raras y no
controladas como aquí donde las
controlamos
el jardín ha evolucionado a lo largo de
los siglos pero siempre según las reglas
del arte topiario es el arte de la
escultura vegetal entre la estética y la
geometría
puedes ver claramente los cubos hay
espirales
Todo se mide se trabaja a nivel siempre
que sea plano o vertical trabajamos a
nivel
contamos también con astucias
como aquí este trozo de bambú nos da el
seno
después también hay que dar Un paso
atrás para ver el efecto que da el ojo
permite corregir Pocoyó cada año 7000
turistas disfrutan perderse por los
espléndidos senderos de este parque en
el sur de Francia en la punta se
encuentra la villa e-no-jook una lujosa
residencia de finales del siglo XIX
construida según los planos de la
Arquitecto de la ópera Garnier profamosa
sobre todo por su entorno de flores un
jardín de rosas como lechos de estrellas
Esta es la princesa de Mónaco es
elegante hermosa refinada al mismo
tiempo junto a la princesa de Mónaco
está la rosa filirete era una persona
fuerte cuando llegaba reventaba
literalmente la pantalla como este
conjunto
jardines que hacen la reputación de la
villa y long con un olivario una vista
impresionante de la Bahía de los
multimillonarios un parque de 11
hectáreas que se puede visitar de forma
gratuita Pero esto no siempre ha sido el
caso a finales del siglo 19 se cobraba
la entrada a los jardines y el producto
de las visitas se donaba a
organizaciones benéficas Como por
ejemplo la good de Led que servía para
enseñar a las madres jóvenes a amamantar
a sus niños era extremadamente raro los
jardines no estaban abiertos a la
población es difícil imaginar que esta
tierra originalmente era solo un montón
de piedras Vila el ojo fue construida en
1860 por un holandés adinerado para su
esposa
destino terminó en su contra ya que a la
esposa no le gustó el lugar se fue y se
dice que loco de pena vendió el lugar
por una décima parte de su valor en la
década de 1930 la casa y los jardines
fueron escenario de grandes recepciones
donde se agolpaba la élite de la
sociedad luego en 1982 el propietario
donó elon hocke la ciudad de antiba con
una condición Que la rosa le da
permaneciera abierta al público y a
todos os la Montes de los jardines más
bellos de Francia